dangerous driving falling for the wrong
person and dancing with cartoon birds
these movies really tested the limits of
how much an actor could take
the dark claustrophobic sets and
constantly gushing water made for some
difficult days on the set of James
Cameron's 1989 sci-fi flick the abyss
but one day stands out for Mary
Elizabeth Master Antonio while filming a
scene in which Ed Harris performs CPR on
her Cameron directed Harris to actually
slap Master Antonio he had to repeat the
slop when the take was obstructed by
Harris's arm after the next take was
botched when the camera ran out of film
Master Antonio actually got up and left
the set she stayed away for hours
leaving Harris to practice with a
sandbag until she was ready to finish
filming the scene Captain America Civil
War focuses on the rift between the
Avengers as the US government tries to
limit their reach this new oversight is
partially inspired by the exploits of
the Winter Soldier AKA Bucky Barnes who
is being pursued by various factions in
an attempt to keep his old friend out of
Harm's Way Steve Rogers played by Chris
Evans tries to get to him before anyone
else can in a dramatic chase scene Bucky
attempts to escape by flying away in a
helicopter this prompts Rogers to try to
keep the powerful vehicle grounded with
his own two hands in an impressive feat
of strength he actually manages to bring
the helicopter crashing down however
filming this scene was so intense that
it left him injured speaking to ET
online Evans remarked and I actually
messed up my oh I'm doing it I really
did according to Evans this stunt wasn't
created through special effects he's
truly straining to keep this helicopter
under control he explained it's a fake
helicopter obviously but it was drifting
beyond the ability of control I tweaked
a little something to this day I'm still
messed up while on the set of the 2002
Thriller Panic Room director David
Fincher told the New York Times I felt
like I needed to be more attentive to
watching the actors he put that theory
into motion for his next film zodiac a
period piece about the search for the
Zodiac Killer whom murdered their way
through Northern California in the 1970s
Jake Gyllenhaal who starred as
cartoonist turned crime reporter Robert
graysmith bore the brunt of Fincher's
commitment to putting his actors through
the ringer according to Gyllenhaal for
one scene Fincher required 70 takes for
another he asked for 90 plus because the
film was shot digitally pincher could
spontaneously delete a slew of takes all
at once Gyllenhaal said but there is a
stopping point there's a point at which
you go that's what we have to work with
but we would reshoot things
although it was far from her first major
role Kate Winslet's performance in
Titanic launched her to worldwide
stardom but filming the movie was not a
pleasant experience the telegraph
reports that there were multiple issues
on set that caused both the cast and
crew to question whether they wanted to
remain part of the project at all
but these ship counts she's made of iron
sir I assure you she can one
particularly troubling moment came when
Winslet filmed a scene in the water
according to the times she genuinely
feared she might drown in the set's
gargantuan water tank things were so
rough she even expressed a desire to
steer clear of director James Cameron in
the future as reported by the guardian
Winslet said he has a temper like you
wouldn't believe you'd have to pay me a
lot of money to work with Jim again
years later however she's softened her
stance the pair collaborated on avatar
the way of water Quentin Tarantino's
Kill Bill movies follow Beatrix kiddo
AKA The Bride As she seeks revenge on
the deadly Viper assassination Squad
years earlier the group betrayed her by
killing her groom to be and putting her
in a coma now she's back on her feet and
ready to dispense Justice Uma Thurman
shines as the deadly kiddo earning
International Acclaim for her
performance in the second movie a scene
in which kiddo drives a car with Steely
determination proved to be problematic
as the New York Times eventually
revealed Tarantino pushed Thurman to
drive the vehicle herself despite her
well-founded concerns that it would be
unsafe those fears were soon Justified
when the car hit a tree causing serious
injuries that Thurman still deals with
to this day she revealed that
immediately after the incident she was
scared she would be unable to walk again
Thurman remarked I went from being a
creative contributor and performer to
being like a broken tool after a 15-year
battle to get footage of the crash
Tarantino finally surrendered it to
Thurman but as Thurman herself noted
this can't undo the damage that was done
or the pain that still lingers in the
1993 film What's Eating Gilbert Grape
Johnny Depp starred as the titular
Gilbert a guy stuck in a small town
caring for his developmentally disabled
younger brother and their housebound
Mother cast as the mom was Darlene Cates
an acting novice that director Lassa
hallstrom spotted on the Sally Jesse
Raphael Show discussing her own struggle
with obesity Depp was going through some
personal stuff during the film's shoot
and was using alcohol to cope hallstrom
later told Entertainment Weekly that he
also empathized with his character a bit
too much it was more that he could
relate to the troubled family life and
the desire to get out of a small town
situation Depp was in such a sensitive
place that he had trouble filming scenes
where the character had to make
disparaging comments about his mother
case recalled that each night after
those scenes were shot Depp called her
to apologize she explained he here he is
the professional he's done all this
stuff before but I thought what a
tribute to his kindness that he would
take the time to consider that I might
be hurt by what he said
shimmering armor
did you know that
to do his job killing bad guys and
foiling terrorist plots 007 needs to use
the firearm on occasion
[Music]
one of the actors who portrayed Bond on
screen had a really hard time with those
moments Roger Moore starred in 7007
movies including the spy who loved me
Moonraker and ironically The Man with
the Golden Gun while he doesn't regret
playing James Bond according to the BBC
Moore once said I regret that sadly
heroes in general are depicted with guns
in their hands and to tell the truth I
have always hated guns and what they
represent it all goes back to his
childhood in his Memoir my word is my
bond Moore said that as a boy he was
rendered deaf for a few days when a gun
blew up in his hands a few years later a
friend shot a BB gun into the future
star's leg when he'd have to use a
firearm on screen more would squeeze his
eyes tightly in discomfort as he pulled
the trigger on his prop Walther PPK
firearm by the time he filmed his final
Bond movie he publicly lamented that the
film series had quote turned so violent
in Quentin Tarantino's Django Unchained
Jamie Foxx plays Django Freeman a
formerly enslaved man who joins Dr King
Schultz to rescue his wife from fearsome
Plantation owner Calvin J candy played
by Leonardo DiCaprio as you would expect
from a Tarantino movie Django Unchained
contains lots of stylized violence gory
fight scenes and plenty of foul language
including a number of racist slurs
DiCaprio took issue with his dialogue
which required him to use these ugly
terms multiple times as Metro Dakota UK
revealed the actor needed outside advice
to move forward with the brutal script
both Fox and Samuel L Jackson
urged him to perform the dialogue as it
was written for the sake of authenticity
though he did manage to move forward
DiCaprio said that he found bling candy
incredibly tough the actor remarked it
was this incredibly interesting horrific
character I mean there was absolutely
nothing about this man I could identify
with the psychological horror film Black
Swan is memorable for many reasons it
was a huge box office hit earning more
than 300 million dollars against its
budget of 13 million dollars it also won
a vast array of awards including five
nominations from the 2011 Oscars Natalie
Portman Stars this promising ballet
dancer Nina Sayers who struggles to cope
with the demands of portraying the Dual
role of Odette and odile in
Tchaikovsky's Swan Lake she soon forms
the Rivalry with fellow dancer Lily
played by Mila Kunis and slowly begins
to lose touch with reality at one point
in the film Kunis and Portman's
characters lock themselves in a room and
end up in bed together a scene that was
something of a trial for both actresses
in an interview with parade kudas
revealed that Chi and Portman knew the
scene would be a Hot Topic it wasn't
done for shock value but we weren't
looking forward to it I don't think we
were laughing between takes I think we
were like let's just get this over with
it's uncomfortable doing a sex scene
it's just bizarre Portland can confirmed
this in a conversation with MTV News it
was pretty awkward I almost feel like it
would be easier to do it with someone
you didn't know that said both Portman
and Kunis agreed that their friendship
made the whole process smoother before
Horrible Bosses there was nine to five
this dark comedy from 1980 centered on
three overworked overlooked female
secretaries enacting brutal revenge on a
chauvinistic Pig of a manager played by
Dabney Coleman Dolly Parton Lily Tomlin
and Jane Fonda headed up the cast with
Fonda also producing but a mere week
after filming began Tomlin tried to quit
what set off the legendary comic actress
she watched the raw footage of herself
and was embarrassed by her performance
particularly the scenes for a Snow White
inspired animated fantasy sequence where
she acted opposite a yet to be created
cartoon bird on The Late Show with
Stephen Colbert Tomlin explained and I
was talking to the birds that weren't
there yeah yeah and I was not doing a
good job and I thought oh this is I'm
gonna be horrible in this despite her
reservations she's stuck with the film
and an 80s classic was born during
production of the first fast and furious
movie series regular and all-around
badass Michelle Rodriguez actually
considered walking away over concerns
with the way her character bloody Ortiz
was written specifically Rodriguez took
a shoe with the way the script called
for Letty to betray her true love Dom
and fall for undercover cop Brian she
felt this betrayal made no sense for a
woman who clearly preferred in her words
the alphaist of alpha males to a pretty
boy refusing to compromise her vision of
Letty Rodriguez put her foot down
telling producers she'd quit the movie
if she had to fortunately for Fast and
Furious fans the storyline was tweaked
to Rodriguez's liking and the rest is
Blockbuster history
scoring in one of the most anticipated
movies of the century is an opportunity
most actors would kill for but the
pressure of filming 2015 Star Wars the
Force awakens nearly proved too much for
Daisy Ridley the British newcomer didn't
have much experience before JJ Abrams
Caster as Rey and screamran reports that
she almost quit on the first day when he
told her that her performance during a
desert scene felt wooden that note along
with bearing the weight of the biggest
franchise in movie history almost
prompted Ridley to get on the Starship
to anywhere far far away
Shelley Duvall sent a Guinness World
Record for her portrayal of Wendy in
Stanley Kubrick's 1980 horror classic
The Shining but it's not a record anyone
would want the perfectionist kuber
consisted on 127 takes of a scene where
Duvall's hysterical character uses a bat
to fend off a deranged Jack Nicholson by
the end she was so exhausted and
dehydrated from crying that she nearly
quit she didn't but the stress of
filming the scene was bad enough that
she reportedly began losing her hair
before she landed leading roles in huge
Blockbusters like Avatar and Guardians
of the Galaxy Zoe Saldana was just
another struggling actress getting by on
bit Parts she had a small one as Anna
Maria in 2003's Pirates of the Caribbean
the Curse of the Black Pearl and she
said she was treated so badly that she
nearly quit telling The Hollywood
Reporter it was very elitist people
disrespected me because they look at my
number on a call sheet and they think
that I'm not important it was so
demoralizing Saldana said she even
considered quitting acting altogether
Mike Myers created the character Wayne
Campbell on Saturday Night Live and the
reoccurring sketch became so popular
that Paramount wanted a Wayne's World
movie Myers wrote the screenplay and he
was especially excited about the scene
where Wayne and the boys pack into the
mirth mobile and headbank to Queen's
Bohemian Rhapsody but the studio wanted
to replace the song with something
fresher and cheaper to license Myers
thought the queen song was crucial as he
revealed on WTF with Marc Maron both
Myers and Bohemian Rhapsody stayed Gene
Hackman won an Oscar for his turn as New
York City police detective Jimmy Popeye
Doyle in 1971's The French Connection
but it almost didn't happen a
notoriously difficult actor he often
clashed with director William friedkin
especially after friedkin revealed that
Paul Newman was his first choice for the
part things came to a head in a scene
where Hackman dressed in a Santa Claus
costume tackles a criminal on the street
freaking demanded 27 takes and Hackman
nearly quit fortunately he stayed and
even mentioned it in his speech at the
Academy Awards
few wrestling stars are bigger than John
Cena so when WWE produced the direct to
video cop Thriller 12 rounds in 2009
casting him as the lead was a no-brainer
although his day job is to battle
hulking beasts in the ring Cena
apparently isn't Fearless one scene
called for his character to repel down a
skyscraper and dangle mid-air from a
rope but Cena revealed later that his
severe fear of heights triggered intense
anxiety and he considered walking away
before he even got up there
a big part of the fourth Rocky movie
involves Rocky's Mentor Apollo Creed
staging a comeback played by former NFL
linebacker Carl Weathers Creek gets
roughed up in the ring pretty bad by
communist pugilist Ivan Drago played by
Dolph Lundgren but one of the boxing
scenes got a little too real when
Lundgren threw weathers into a corner
causing weathers to break character and
throw a real punch Lundgren responded in
kind knocking weathers out when he
regained Consciousness he quit the movie
and sent production into limbo for four
days that's when Sylvester Stallone
finally convinced weathers to return
Alfred Hitchcock had a reputation for
being unkind to actresses but Tippy
hendren signed on to 1963's the birds
under the guarantee that she'd only be
attacked with mechanical Birds during
the film's climactic scene but Hitchcock
is the king of twists and he wanted
hedrin's Terror to feel real so he
instructed crew members to throw real
live birds at her this real-life game of
Angry Birds went on for five full days
and hedron had a breakdown when it was
over she only finished the movie when a
doctor ordered Hitchcock to give her a
week off to recover The Walking Dead
nearly suffered what would have been a
devastating loss in season three when
Lauren Cohan who plays Maggie
contemplated quitting over a
particularly stressful scene after
reading the script and realizing Maggie
was supposed to perform an emergency
C-section on Lori Grimes while the
character's son looked on she took her
concerns to co-star Stephen young
explaining she was worried it would be
too intense but after further
consideration that's exactly why she
decided to stay recognizing that The
Walking Dead is a show about people
pushed to grueling extremes she Drew on
her discomfort to deliver an effectingly
honest performance you think you hated
Fox's first couple of Fantastic Four
movies try being Jessica Alba whose
experience is playing Sue Invisible
Woman storm nearly made her walk away
from acting altogether Alba's
frustration stemmed from working with
director Tim story who she later claimed
issued absurd demands like telling her
to keep her facial expression flat
during a crying scene so she'd stay
pretty after 2007's Rise of the Silver
Surfer she realized she didn't care
about the movie business anymore and has
been more selective about acting
projects but things have still worked
out pretty well for her she went on to
co-found the Honest Company currently
valued around 1 billion dollars
Interview with the Vampire United Tom
Cruise and Brad Pitt in a visually
Sumptuous adaptation of the best-selling
Anne Rice novel but being part of 1994's
most eagerly anticipated Beefcake Summit
wasn't all it was cracked up to be for
Pitt years after the movie came and went
Pitt admitted he was so miserable during
filming that he actually approached
producer David Geffen about buying out
his contract only to reconsider after
Geffen informed him it cost 40 million
dollars it's hard to imagine Gandalf
being played by anyone other than sir
Ian McKellen who played the wizard in
all six Lord of the Rings and Hobbit
films but if things had worked out a
little differently during the filming of
The Hobbit an Unexpected Journey
director Peter Jackson might have had to
find a different actor that's because
McKellen was acting almost exclusively
to a green screen since his character
towered over the hobbits and their
interactions had to be stitched together
digitally the frustration of acting
alone eventually got to McKellen who
broke down on the set at one point
Jackson did a little emergency Outreach
to convince him to stick around round
and the crew held a Gandalf appreciation
day and decorated his tent with Lord of
the Rings mementos
Marvel's The Avengers was such a huge
ambitious project that it attracted
actors who usually don't do comic book
movies including two-time Oscar nominee
Jeremy Renner as Clint Barton AKA
Hawkeye while some of the more famous
heroes in the movie like Iron Man the
Hulk Captain America got to do more
interesting things Hawkeye spent most of
the Avengers as the brainwashed servant
of villain Loki Brenner was displeased
he explained during a q a event I was
just getting to know who Hawkeye was and
then zap I go around like a zombie
unlike Loki's minion but don't worry
Renner took it like a champ just kidding
he soaked in whined about it he later
recalled that in each scene he'd make
horrible audible grunts of pain when
asked why by The Crew He said I'm giving
you an option if you just want to kick
me out of this movie just you know at
any given moment if you want to kill me
off daddy's gonna be having a heart
attack
oh